today's video is brought to you by
Squarespace the all-in-one platform for
building your brand and growing your
business more on them in a bit compared
to his father Alfred the Great Edward
the Elder was described by medieval
Chronicles as much inferior in
literature but greatly excelled in
extent of power and it was true Alfred
played a pivotal role in the history of
England when he became the only
Anglo-Saxon King to successfully fight
off the Viking Invasion he then spent
the rest of his Reign fortifying his
kingdom to ensure that Wessex would
never face a similar threat again but
now was time for Edward to take off the
kid clubs and go on the offensive Edward
like his father had a vision of a
unified England under his rule of course
but he had a tough task ahead of him
with enemies to the north and east
across the channel and even within his
own kingdom but he overcame obstacles
and vanquished his foes as best he could
ensuring that the kingdom of England
became a reality even though it was not
the one to wear the crown
foreign
early years
Edward's early years are surprisingly
obscured even though his dad was Alfred
the Great the self-proclaimed King of
the Anglo-Saxons who had his own
chronicler on stand by it seems that
details such as the birds of his
children were just too minor to bother
to ride down so we're not really sure
when or where Edward was born an
educated guess however would suggest
Circa mid-870s somewhere in Wessex it
could be worse we suppose when it came
to Edward's mother and Alfred's wife the
aforementioned chronic color Assa did
not even mention her by name we do now
however from other sources that her name
oh is arswiss she was the daughter of a
mercy and no woman named Ethel redmusel
not to be confused with Alfred's older
brother ethelrid the first who served as
king before him who in turn should not
be confused with Ethel read the unready
the more famous King who came about a
century later earlsworth and Alfred got
married in 868 A.D back when he was
still Prince and heir to the Kingdom of
Wessex they had five children together
who survived to adulthood ever played uh
the oldest sibling and she married a
mercian lord whose name was yes you
guessed it Ethel red Edward was the
oldest son of Alfred but he did not
become known as Edward the Elder to
distinguish himself from a younger
brother nor did he ever have a son by
that name in fact he was never called
Edward the Elder in his own lifetime
this Monica was applied retroactively to
separate him from the next Edward who
came to Rule the Kingdom a hundred years
later Edward the Martyr succession
always another murky topic back in the
19th century one uh which had evolved
over time as the eldest son of King
Alfred Edward was in a prime position to
inherit his kingdom but it wasn't
exactly a done deal Primo genitour or
the right of the firstborn to inherit
had not yet become the norm although
Alfred had named Edward as his successor
a council known as the witan still had a
say in the matter especially in
circumstances where there was more than
one strong claim into the throne and as
it happened Edward faced some stiff
competition remember that Alfred's older
brother Ethel red was king of Wessex
before him and Alfred only Rose the
throne after his brother's desk but
Ethel red also had two sons Ethel Helm
and Ethel world at the time of their
father's death both were infants which
was oh why they were passed over in
favor of Alfred but that did not mean
that they gave up their rights forever
as the sons of the king of Wessex their
claim was just as strong as Edwards
Ethel Helm did not prove to be a problem
the only trace of his existence was a
mention of him and his brother
contesting Alfred's will after that he
completely vanished from the historical
record so presumably he died sometime
before the matter of succession ever
came up ethelworld on the other hand had
no intention of going out without a
fight so if Edward wanted to become the
new king of wessigs and maybe one day
unite all of England he would have to go
through him first so are you looking to
build your brand and grow your business
online well I have got the perfect
sponsor for you it's Square sway
Squarespace is the all-in-one platform
for building your brand and growing your
business online look I've been using
Squarespace for years and it completely
revolutionized the way that I made a
website it's so easy to use and and
customize and the best part is that it
is super affordable one of their best
relatively new features is member areas
it's perfect for creators and Educators
who want to monetize their content and
expertise by selling access to gated
content like classes online courses or
even newsletters I mean who wouldn't
want to unlock a new Revenue stream for
their business am I right and let's not
forget about squarespace's email
campaigns with this feature you could
easily collect email subscribers and
convert them into law customers start
with an email template customize it
apply your brand colors and logo and
boom you're good to go plus the built-in
analytics measure the impact of every
cent and for those of you who want to
support a course Squarespace makes it
easy with the collect donations feature
you can gather contributions via paper
Apple pay stripe and venmo it's perfect
for Charities and non-profits and anyone
who wants to make a difference so what
are you waiting for head to
squarespace.com and start your free
trial today and when you're ready to
launch go to squarespace.com biographics
to save 10 of your first purchase of a
website or domain using the code
biographics thanks again to Squarespace
for the sponsorship and now back to
today's video
[Music]
in 899 A.D Alfred the Great passed away
and Edward was crowned the new King on
Whit Sunday according to the chronicles
of the time Edward was elected by The
Nobles without any issue however the
actions that followed suggested
otherwise Alfred had made his own wishes
clear in an earlier Charter he had
Edward recorded as king alongside
himself it was obvious that he wanted
Edward to succeed him on the throne but
it seems that not everyone was on board
with that idea ASA Walt had surprisingly
strong support made even more surprising
by the fact that Alfred was supposed to
be the savior of the Anglo-Saxons the
king who stopped the Vikings from taking
over all of England it had been over a
decade since Alfred decisively defeated
guthrum at the Battle of erdington and
pushed back the Viking Invasion so maybe
people had short Memories Back Then or
maybe Alfred did something to damage his
popularity in the meantime by name we
only know of an elder man named wolf
here from Wiltshire who had some of his
land confiscated by Alfred as punishment
for the exertion it's not hard to
imagine that there were other Nobles who
harbored grudges against Alfred they
would not dare to go against him while
he was alive but now that the King was
dead they were Keen to ensure that his
dynasty got snapped out alongside him as
the world wasted no time in acting as
soon as wood reached him that Alfred had
chopped off his mortal call he gathered
his army and rode to Dorset where he
captured the settlements of Christchurch
and wimborne Christchurch was a
fortified encampment called a bird
Alfred had built dozens of them all over
his kingdom so his men could guard
themselves against surprise Viking raids
it was nice to have but it wasn't
crucial winborne was the true prize
besides its strategic position roughly
straddling the border between the
eastern and western halves of the
kingdom it also had great symbolic value
for aetherwald for starters his father
Ethel red the first was buried there but
he may have also wanted to take part in
a Royal Anglo-Saxon tradition known as
the farm of one night every year in late
Autumn after the Harvest was finished a
royal tribute was gathered several
important Estates in the Kingdom and the
King rode around to collect them some
speculate that aetherwald wanted to be
there in person when the tribute arrived
and claimed the tribute as the rightful
recipient for his part Edward knew that
trouble was brewing an expected
aetherwald to make a move against him he
reacted swiftly once he heard that his
rival had taken over wimborne Edward
gathered his own Army and headed to
Dorset camping in the Old Iron Age Fort
of badbury rings this too was a place of
symbolic power as the nearby town of
badbury was used for political
assemblies but it also blocked
aetherwald's path should he get any
funny ideas about traveling East and
trying to capture Winchester the capital
of the Kingdom of Wessex but it's simply
Edward deftly outmaneuvered his rival
but aselwald was not down for the count
just yet he saw an all-out battle with
Edward as a sure-fire loss so instead he
crossed Murcia and retreated to
northumbria the northernmost Anglo-Saxon
Kingdom which was firmly controlled by
the Danes what kind of support
eighthaward expected to find there oh he
cannot say but the Anglo-Saxon Chronicle
claims that the Danes received him as
their King there are even coins from
that area that mention a king named
waldus and historians Molly but that was
probably a Thor world how he managed it
what he promised them will never know
but now aetherwald had some Viking
muscle as backup and he was ready for
round two in 901 A.D aetherworld
launched the second part of his
Rebellion he sailed with a fleet from
northumbria to East Anglia the other
Kingdom in the hands of the Danes and
once again he made them a counter offer
that they couldn't refuse and gain their
allegiance he then traveled North into
Mercier and secured even more support
there back before Alfred the Great
Mercier was its own kingdom it was
actually the biggest and most powerful
at one point but the Viking raids left
it in a severely weakened state so that
when Alfred and Gotham reached a peace
between the Danes and the Anglo-Saxons
the two divided Mercier and each one
added half to their own domains in
Edward's time Mercier was governed by
his older sister the aforementioned
eighth or flayed and her husband Ethel
red although how much autonomy they
really had is upper debate anyway the
pointers that Mercier had no shortage of
royal families that might have wanted to
extinguish Alfred's bloodline for a
chance of Reviving The Old Glory Days it
had become clear that aetherwald was
doing the rounds through England trying
to unite all those who opposed England
under his Banner he did a pretty good
job of it too so once his army was
raring to go he ventured into Edward's
side of Mercia and let his Vikings do
what they did best Loot and pillage
after that aetherworld crossed the
Thames into Wessex itself capturing the
Fortified Burr of quick blade while all
of this was going on Edward sent his
army into East Anglia to responding kind
this prompted an immediate reaction from
aetherwall who followed Edward's troops
perhaps hoping to trap them and crush
them between two armies as you might
expect this was something that Edward
was eager to avoid so he sent word to
retreat for reasons lost to history as
kentich contingent did not withdraw from
the action despite Edward sending
messages to them on several occasions
What followed next or was the Battle of
the home where after prolonged delays
and raids the two sides finally clashed
Shields wielded swords and shook greatly
the spear in either hand that's about
all we know about this poorly document
of battle we're not even really sure
where the home was but we can say that
the engagement proved disastrous for
both sides for Wessex it was bad because
the kentish forces were almost entirely
obliterated the leader of the kentish
army elderman serial wolf was killed in
battle that was almost every other
kentish Lord the Vikings on the other
hand suffered much fewer losses but
among the dead was none other than
etherwald himself with the leaders of
the Revolt slain in battle the Rebellion
lost all its steam now there was nobody
left who could legitimately challenge
Edward's claim to the throne the Danes
from East Anglia and northumbria kept
fighting for a while but their hearts
were clearly not in it anymore
eventually they struck peace and went
back to binding their own kingdoms while
Edward was now free to rule over Wessex
uncontested
following years of dealing with a
dangerous thorn in his side Edward
decided that it was time for a much
deserved break so the next few years
were pretty quiet with no events of note
being mentioned in the medieval
Chronicles or maybe he simply needed
more time to prepare for his true
ambition the unification of England ever
since his great grandfather Ackman
conquered the kingdoms of Essex Sussex
and Kent and placed them under the Aegis
of Wessex Edward's family wanted to
bring all of England together under
their rule by thwarting the Viking
Invasion and building a strong Kingdom
his father Alfred was in the best
position to do it but he died before he
got his chance however he set the table
nicely for Edward to continue where he
left off and he intended to make full
use of the opportunity in 909 A.D Edward
gathered Army of West Saxons and
mercians and marched into northumbria
Barry embarked on a five-week long
campaign of murder and Mayhem that saw
his army pillage every Danish Town
Village and Hamlet that had the
misfortune of getting in their way this
included at one point raiding the final
resting place of Saint Oswald of
northumbria bard in the Abbey collecting
his holy relics and moving them to
Mercier unsurprisingly the Danes didn't
just take this lying down instead they
also mustered an army and marched South
into Mercia looking to do a little
plundering of their own however Edward
knew this would happen and was ready for
them the two sides fought on August 5th
910 A.D at the Battle of Tatton Hall
where the Anglo-Saxon forces delivered a
crushing defeat to the Vikings again no
specifics but the Danes suffered heavy
losses that numbered in the many
thousands which included two kings
Aerials and half Dan two Earls and many
other Lords following this damn good
wall of in the northern Danes talk tales
and ran back to northumbria and spent
the rest of Edward's Reign licking their
wounds no longer a threat this allowed
the king of Wessex to turn his attention
to his enemies to the east unfortunately
for Edward the victory up north was soon
followed by a setback in 911 A.D he lost
one of his strongest allies his
brother-in-law Ethel red who had been
the nominal ruler of the angdos acts
inside of Mercia however his widow Ed
Edward's sister eighth or fled was
already and willing to pick up the slack
Edward assumed Direct Control of some
major cities such as London and Oxford
but the rest of the territory was placed
in Aether fled's hands who took the
title of a lady of the mercians taking a
page out of their father's book the
brother and sister combo spent the next
five years Shoring up their defenses by
building new birds and fortresses
throughout Their Kingdoms this strategy
paid off it was not as flashy or
thrilling as riding into battle with
raised swords glinting in the Sun but it
was effective and took advantage of the
fact that the Viking power was
decentralized and disseminated among all
the major cities under their control the
Danes from York weren't on the same page
as the Danes in Essex or Cambridge and
Edward understood that a display of
overwhelming power would have been
enough to persuade most of them to
submit to him and he was right for the
most part the Anglo-Saxon Chronicle
tells us that many settlements both in
East Anglia and Mercia showed submission
to King Edward rather than fighting him
we can't tell you what this submission
really meant were they officially part
of his kingdom were they vassals did
they pay tribute or send him a Christmas
card it's all pretty murky but it is
highly likely that some of the more
powerful Viking leaders retained a
significant degree of autonomy it's not
like the Agreements are a set in stone
or anything Edward knew that whenever
Vikings got the itch they would go out
plundering treaties be damned in 917 A.D
right after Easter an army of Danes out
of Northampton and Leicester broke the
truce and sacked the town of hookton
such raids were always going to happen
but thanks to Edward's network of Burrs
none of them got the chance to develop
into a more serious threat then a show
of force was usually enough to get
everyone to settle down like in 919 when
Edward marched with his army and
conquered Bedford prompting all of the
nearby settlements to reaffirm their
allegiance to him
[Music]
after a few years like this Edward the
Elder held a tenuous grip over most of
England he didn't have the money
soldiers or resources to outright
capture and incorporate all of the
territories under a single Kingdom but
is slowly but surely approach saw his
sphere of influence get larger and
larger it seemed like all he needed was
time up in the north atherflight was
doing Herbert to help out the family
Legacy it was said that by 918 A.D all
of the Danish settlement south of the
Humber had offered their submission
although to who exactly they submitted
is another matter of contention it's
pretty clear that Edward and etherflight
acted in tandem when it came to
fortifying Their Kingdoms but that could
not prevent a little sibling rivalry
from developing the mercy and register
for example was careful to specify that
the Danish Army submitted to eighth or
float with no kind of submission towards
Edward indicated or implied the
Anglo-Saxon Chronicle however which was
basically his side of the story only
mentioned Edward and not Aether flight
it is possible that the big sis was no
longer content City in her little
brother's Shadow when she was doing half
the work but fate decided to put an end
to their issues before any simmering
resentments had a chance to boil over
into an all-out sibling squabble in 900
1880 Ethel fled died and she was buried
at Gloucester she didn't have any sons
so she was succeeded by her daughter
Athen Flynn but not for long just a few
months after Aether Blade's death Edward
decided to take Direct Control of Mercia
while his niece was deprived of all
dominion over the mercians and carried
into Wessex three weeks before midwinter
this was probably another sign that
things had not been completely cool
between brother and sister or perhaps it
was just simply a precautionary step
from Edward after what had happened with
his cousin aetherwald he may have
decided that it was safer not to let his
close blood relatives roam free and
unchecked just in case one of them might
try to stay who claim for the throne
later on this is all just pure guesswork
by the way some scholars believe that
athewin was eventually married off to a
nobleman While others think it's more
likely that she joined the church
ultimately her fate remains a mystery
once the other Anglo-Saxon kingdoms were
under Edward's influence to varying
degrees the king of Wessex turned his
attention to Wales and Scotland Wales
didn't proved too difficult it was
already under Edward's auspices ever
since he came to their rescue in 918
when a powerful Viking Fleet held from
Britain he led by two Earls ocher
enrolled they plundered North Wales and
took the bishop of arch and field
hostage however King Edward paid his
Ransom and then raised an army from
Hartford and Gloucester and defeated the
Invaders killing role and sending the
Vikings back to their shores as thanks
for his assistance in 920 A.D the kings
of North Wales Hal the good and clydork
both recognized Edward as their Overlord
more interesting and mysterious was
Edward's status in Scotland we're going
by the chronicle again here which wrote
that the king of the Scots sent all the
people of the Scots and ragnalds and
other sons of Eid wolf and all those who
live in northumbria both English and
danish Norsemen and other and also the
king of the Straz Clyde Welsh and all
the Clyde Welsh chose him as father and
Lord how and why this Arrangement came
about is Up For Debate no contemporary
sources present any valid reasons why
ragnald an independent and powerful King
who ruled over parts of Scotland
northumbria and the Isle of Man Would
count her before Edward at least not
without a little scrap first and modern
historians think it's more likely that
their agreement was more of a peace
treaty between equal Nations instead of
oh one submitting to the other but as we
said the Anglo-Saxon Chronicle was
Edward's version of events we've all
lied on our resumes on occasion and
being chosen as father-in-lawed sounds a
lot more impressive than simply
negotiating a peace treaty the last few
years of Edward's Reign were a bit dull
but practical once more he mirrored his
father's approach who spent his waning
years building fortifications and tried
to improve his Kingdom's literacy
appears but Edward traveled from town to
town helping to rebuild and improve them
some of the locations mentioned by name
include Nottingham Stanford towerchester
again just like Alfred the Great Edward
might have felt that his time was coming
to an end even though he still had
unfinished work to do but he would not
give up either and instead he
strengthened his kingdom as much as
possible so that his own son could take
up the family Quest and he was right in
924 A.D Edward the Elder died and was
buried in Winchester he passed the Baton
to his son ethelstan who succeeded him
and brought his father and grandfather's
ambition to fruition by becoming the
first king of England but that's a story
that will cover another time
foreign
[Music]